[Music]
caution a memorandum of a telephone
conversation is not a verbatim
transcript of a discussion the text in
this document records the notes and
recollections of situation room duty
officers and NSC policy staff assigned
to listen and memorialize the
conversation in written form the United
States has been very very good to
Ukraine I wouldn't say that it's
reciprocal necessarily because things
are happening that are not good but the
United States has been very very good to
Ukraine yes you are absolutely right not
only 100% but actually 1000% and I can
tell you the following I did talk to
Angela Merkel and I did meet with her I
also met and talked with Makran and I
told them that they are not doing quite
as much as they need to be doing on the
issues with the sanctions they're not
enforcing the sanctions they're not
working as much as they should work for
Ukraine it turns out that even though
logically the European Union should be
our biggest partner but technically the
United States is a much bigger partner
than the European Union and I'm very
grateful to you for that because the
United States is doing quite a lot for
Ukraine much more than the European
Union especially when we were talking
about sanctions against the Russian
Federation I would like you to do as a
favor though because our country has
been through a lot and Ukraine knows a
lot about it I'd like you to find out
what happened with this whole situation
with Ukraine they say CrowdStrike
I guess you have one of your wealthy
people the server they say Ukraine has
it there were a lot of things that went
on the whole situation I think you're
surrounding yourself with some of the
same people I would like to have the
Attorney General call you or your people
and I would like you to get to the
bottom of it as you saw yesterday that
whole nonsense ended with a very poor
performance by an a man named Robert
Muller an incompetent performance but
they say a lot of it started with
Ukraine whatever you can do it's very
important that you do it if that's
possible yes it is very important for me
and everything that you just mentioned
earlier for me as a president it is very
important and we are open for any future
cooperation we are ready to open a new
page on cooperation
relations between the United States and
Ukraine for that purpose I just recalled
our ambassador from United States and he
will be replaced by a very competent and
very experienced ambassador who will
work hard on making sure that our two
nations are getting closer I would also
like and hope to see him having your
trust and your confidence and have
personal relations with you so we can
cooperate even more so I will personally
tell you that one of my assistants spoke
with mr. Giuliani just recently and we
were hoping very much that mr. Giuliani
will be able to travel to Ukraine and we
will meet once he comes to Ukraine good
because I heard you had a prosecutor who
was very good and he was shut down and
that's really unfair a lot of people are
talking about that the way they shut be
a very good prosecutor down and you had
some very bad people involved mr.
Giuliani is a highly respected man he
was the mayor of New York City a great
mayor and I would like him to call you I
will ask him to call you along with the
Attorney General
Rudy very much knows what's happening
and he is a very capable guy if you
could speak to him that would be great
the former ambassador from the United
States
the woman was bad news and the people
she was dealing with in the Ukraine were
bad news so I just want to let you know
that the other thing there's a lot of
talk about Biden's son that Biden stop
the prosecution and a lot of people want
to find out about that so whatever you
can do with the attorney general would
be great
Biden went around bragging that he
stopped the prosecution so if you can
look into it
it sounds horrible to me I wanted to
tell you about the prosecutor first of
all I understand and I'm knowledgeable
about this situation since we have won
the absolute majority in our Parliament
the next prosecutor general will be 100%
my person my candidate who will be
approved by the Parliament and will
start as a new prosecutor in September
he or she will look into the situation
specifically to the company that you
mentioned in this issue the issue of the
investigation of the case is actually
the issue of making sure to restore the
honesty so we will take care of that and
we'll work on the investigation of the
case on top of that I would kindly ask
you if you have any additional
information that you can provide to us
it would be very helpful for the
investigation to make sure that we
administer justice in our country with
regard to the ambassador to the
it states from Ukraine as far as I
recall her name was Evanovich I will
have mr. Giuliani give you a call and
I'm also gonna have attorney general bar
call and we will get to the bottom of it
I'm sure you will figure it out I would
like to tell you that I also have quite
a few Ukrainian friends that live in the
United States actually the last time I
traveled to the United States I stayed
in New York near Central Park and I
stayed at the Trump Tower I will talk to
them and I hope to see them again in the
future I also wanted to thank you for
your invitation to visit the United
States specifically Washington DC on the
other hand I also want to ensure you
that we will be very serious about the
case and will work on the investigation